it's just past 1500 GMT and we start
this NewsHour with a conflict in Sudan
which is now in its fourth month and
showing no signs of easing millions of
people have been displaced at least a
hundred thousands of a thousand have
fled to neighboring countries and those
who've gone to Chad from the Western
Darfur region have been speaking about
what they experiences they try to escape
the regional capital al-janina
the international criminal court at the
Hague is now investigating suspected war
crimes in Darfur refugees and Witnesses
say gunmen are killing and torturing
civilians and leaving piles of burned
bodies behind
I was among a group of 37 people ordered
by the militias specifically the rapid
support forces to cover the bodies I
know of six similar groups in the city
we were given iron hooks with which we
dragged the bodies covered them in
plastic sheets and then placed them in
trucks that are transporting
construction materials the group picked
up more than 300 corpses in three days
on the orders of the Armed men
Camp I have four children who were shot
also after a shell that fell on us I
lost my granddaughter in addition I lost
two sons they were shot 15 days ago and
they haven't arrived yet of course
whoever is shot and missing we consider
them finished dead
if they suspect any person they shoot
him directly and this one has a broken
leg he was shot directly they will not
have mercy on him people in uniform are
doing The Killing and they have heavy
weapons I can't tell you who kills but
they are not from the government I saw a
number of dead people dumped in the
streets in areas you find two sometimes
five and sometimes you find a group so I
slept in the street and the second day I
continued walking and in the street
again I saw dead people dumped others
were running away they came out in the
street at night to escape what happened
in junina and they were killed in
ambushes on the road you would find
checkpoints and they would search US
telling us to give them our phones and
money they targeted young people old men
like us they didn't push us as much
well Heather Morgan joins us now from
OnDemand near the Sudanese capital and
hibber a catalog of harrowing
testimonies there what more of have
witnesses been saying
while people have been giving horrific
accounts of what they leave behind in
generating into Aid workers to
journalists to friends and to relatives
who they can find in refugee camps many
of them say that people from the masalis
who have been injured in the conflict or
in the violence and go to hospitals are
targeted even inside the hospitals they
say that those wounded are forced to be
left behind because they cannot take the
distance and because it's very hard to
travel with an injured person when
you're being targeted and as you try to
Flee for Your Life so these testimonies
are just some of the many many
testimonies that uh refugees who arrive
in neighboring Chad fleeing from Janina
have been giving to Aid workers rights
groups and journalists now the violence
there's as a result of a malicious Ally
to the rapid support forces targeting
People based on their ethnicities that's
what the survivors have been telling
journalists and Aid workers and rights
groups upon their arrival in refugee
camps in address in neighboring Chad
many of them say that they don't know if
they're loved ones and family members
who they leave behind are still alive or
are lost many of them say that they try
to embark on a journey of searching for
potentially alive family members and
refugee camps who may have come after
them or may have come before them but
they all give the same testimonies that
they've been targeted that they were
malicious and that they were supported
by the paramilitary rapid support forces
and that there's been no government
response to protect them and protect
their properties from those attacks yeah
but they do really sound like desperate
accounts and as you know the conflict
has caused a surge in cases of rape and
the Abduction of women and girls of the
United Nations says it's documented more
than 50 cases since fighting began
nearly three months ago
since conflict broke out in April the
U.N human rights office has received
credible reports of violations against
over 50 women and girls in a single
attack as many as 20 women were
reportedly raped
this week I received additional
information of the targeting of medical
infrastructure and staff providing
support to victims of sexual violence as
well as an increase in Abduction of
women and girls
and Heber of course the backdrop to all
of this violence is the ongoing conflict
between the rapid support forces and the
military where are we with that conflict
now
it's still very much ongoing it's now in
its fourth month there's no sign of it's
ending anytime soon with many political
uh or rather resolutions and initiatives
being put forward uh to the worrying
sides but very few being uh accepted or
welcomed by both sides at the same time
now here in the city of onderman in the
early hours of Saturday we were able to
hear Heavy Artillery being fired between
the paramilitary rapid support forces
and the Sudanese Army just a short while
ago there was an airstrike in the
northern part of the city of umderman
and just prior to that there was a drone
attack by the paramilitary rapid support
forces targeting the military Hospital
in the uh southern part of the city of
androman now there's also been fighting
reported in other parts of the capital
as well and uh talks between the two
sides to bring an end to this conflict
or to result in some kind of a ceasefire
to allow for humanitarian assistance has
been adjourned in the Saudi city of
Jeddah while the Army says that it
welcomes the initiatives and it does
want to end the conflict it says that
has to ensure that its sovereignty is
maintained that's one thing that the
senior Army officials have been telling
Al Jazeera that they want to ensure that
the sovereignty of the nation is
maintained in all the initiatives that
are being proposed the rsf on the other
hand says it does want to end the
conflict but it also wants certain terms
to be met so while those two sides are
trying to come to some sort of an
agreement and mediators are trying to
get the two sides to agree on something
on the ground here civilians continue to
witness fighting and continue to live
the horrors of the conflict
Heber Morgan in on demand thank you